[Music]
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
Scripps memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the Press of Johan Gutenberg science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
if this is what's going on with colleges
and if they're controlling working
professionals so that the working
professionals have to work in a way that
isn't truthful I mean how do you even
fight how do you fight back against that
at what point do you just stop playing
in that game you know when people have
asked me that too why don't you just
give up your license and I would say
well because I wouldn't be giving it up
I would be allowing it to be taken away
from me like if I decide in a year that
I don't want to be a licensed clinical
psychologist because the whole damn
profession has become corrupt that's a
whole different issue than letting this
pack of Craven commissar cowards utilize
the complaints of random people online
to justify their own envy and desire to
prosecute and then fold in the face of
that opposition it's like I'm not going
to do that the only thing you have in a
complex situation
is the truth
that's all you have that's why you have
to abide by the truth you know because
when things get complex around you all
you have there that's Solid Ground is
the truth and so the reason you abide by
the truth is so that you can say what
you have to say about what you've done
and who you are and you can do that
under impossibly difficult circumstances
and possibly that will sustain you
through that
[Music]
thank you
hello everybody watching and listening
on YouTube and perhaps on The Daily Word
plus platform I'm
being I'm having a discussion today with
my daughter Michaela I asked her to
interview me I suppose about what's
happening in Toronto Ontario Canada at
the moment on the professional front
relationship to me
the Ontario College of psychologists
which is the board that regulates the
practice of psychology in Ontario and
hypothetically protects the public
interest has levied a series of what are
in essence lawsuits against me for
um unprofessional conduct pertaining
primarily to my social Media
communication and so they have decided
in their wisdom
that I am to be required to undertake a
series of re-education
lessons designed to ensure that I
communicate in a manner they deem
appropriate and I have told them that
there are no circumstances I can imagine
under which I would be willing to do
that and the next step is to bring me
before a public disciplinary hearing and
then to suspend my clinical license and
so I'm making all of this public because
I think people need to weigh in on
whether I'm an alt-right Nazi harmful uh
you know Bastion of of Intolerable
political thought with a troll-like army
of pathological followers or whether the
college itself is a corrupt nest of
social justice vipers hell bent on envy
and revenge and using the tiny fraction
of people who are complaining to put
forward their own brand of personal
pathology and vindictiveness and
well I'll make everything public except
for that which I can't do on legal
grounds and let everybody decide for
themselves that's the plan because I
might be wrong and uh I guess if I am I
need to learn how in any case Michaela
is going to talk to me for 90 minutes
and uh we're going to walk through some
of this and maybe you'll find that
interesting and maybe you won't
um why would you care well
that's I guess what you'll figure out if
you listen to the talk one reason might
be it's my opinion that
the regulatory boards that govern
professional conduct in Canada
particularly in the U.S as well and in
the west more broadly have become so
corrupted by the wok ideology that the
professionals you depend on in moments
of Crisis for legal advice and medical
advice and psychological counseling some
of which can be
life and reputation saving they can no
longer be trusted because they're being
required by the professional bodies to
lie to you in the service of this warped
uh radical leftist ideology that's now
become what would you call it mandatory
for right speakers wherever they might
exist and so that's why you might want
to listen and decide for yourself
whether you think that might be true so
anyways onward with the discussion and
thanks Michaela for agreeing to do this
hey guys I'm coming on my dad's channel
to interview him because he's dealing
with some serious things right now like
usual kind of like usual so first off
how are you how are you doing Dad
well
not too bad
um
I've been
preparing my public response to
the decision of the Ontario College of
psychologists to
require me to do mandatory Social Media
communication retraining
they've
they have the College of psychologists
is the regulatory board for the practice
of psychology in Ontario there are
a variety of regulated professions
medicine Dentistry teaching architecture
psychology that's not all of them and
these regulated professions have a board
that's
appointed by the government
whose mandate is to protect the public
from unprofessional behavior on the part
of the members of the regulated
professions and people can submit
complaints to those bodies if they
believe that they've been treated
um unprofessionally or unethically
or otherwise inappropriately by a
College member so a member of the
relevant profession and uh
the college has been after me non-stop
with complaints since I Rose to public
prominence in two thousand and 2016
although not once before that in the 20
years that I practiced as a clinical
psychologist so this isn't the
university that's after me like it was
in
2017 2016. this is the College of
psychologists which has started pursuing
me in 2016 and has never led up now what
happens is that
people anyone anywhere can submit a
complaint about me for anything I've
done or said hypothetical or otherwise
and then the college can and that
doesn't matter if they're a client of
mine or ever have been
or if I've had any dealings with them or
even if they're the person who has
hypothetically been harmed by my
behavior
and the college has decided to pursue a
sequence of such complaints even though
it's in their power to dismiss them as
vexatious or frivolous which is what I
asked for on the grounds that my social
media
communication has caused harm to people
and so they've essentially taken out
what are the equivalent of more than a
dozen lawsuits against me and I say
they're equivalent to lawsuits because
the penalty
for being found guilty of such
misbehaviors quite serious it can
involve re-education public apology or
even the removal of my ability to
practice or to describe myself as a
clinical psychologist and of course took
me about 10 years All Things Considered
to get licensed it's very difficult
process and I'm not inclined to give it
up lightly in any case they have been
after me to a tremendous degree in 2022
I think there's 13 or 14 complaints Each
of which culminated in one of these
lawsuits I'm represented by legal
counsel there's so many of them that
they're difficult to keep track of
um
I probably went through 400 pages of
documentation this week and you asked me
how I'm doing well you know um first of
all I found it extremely difficult to
keep my my rage under control
because a tremendous amount of my time
is being wasted it's extremely expensive
the allegations are not only utterly
preposterous but entirely political in
nature and then I was also afraid of it
you know the first complaint came in
2017
2016 in December
at the same time the University was
after me and at the same time the
Canadian Revenue authorities were after
me for a mistake they admitted making
six months later and you remember that
was an extremely stressful time and I
was accused at that point of
inappropriate personal conduct in
relationship to one of my clients all of
that was uh dismissed by the way without
hesitation although the college did
decide at that point because they needed
to decide I was guilty of something even
though I wasn't guilty of what I was
of what I was most seriously accused of
they decided I hadn't handled my email
properly at that point when I was
getting thousands of emails a day yeah
um and that that made it difficult for
my clients to get a hold of me even
though I had given every single one of
my clients my personal phone number and
could contact me by text which is
something by the way that psychologists
never do you know for for obvious
reasons so in any case it's been a
continuous stream of Investigations and
legal defense since then I found that
kind of accusation of serious personal
misconduct unbelievably stressful in
2016 it certainly contributed to be me
becoming ill yeah and then I didn't
really want to revisit it you know and
so I started going through all that
documentation last week so that I could
lay out everything that's been levied at
me and uh
you know I went through all that stuff
from 2017 even talking about it now it
makes me shake to some degree
um afterwards I could hardly stand up I
like just about fainted three or four
times and you know had a real hard time
keeping myself
composed it's very
off-putting
to let's say to have attempted to
conduct myself extremely carefully in my
professional occupations as a professor
and as a clinical psychologist for
decades you know to to step very
carefully of course I never had any
behavioral accusations levied against me
at Harvard or the University of Toronto
or as a clinical psychologist in the 30
years I was a professor in 20 years of
private practice and then to be accused
of serious personal misconduct the
essential claim was my seductive
Behavior as a therapist and the evidence
uh offered was that when I was offering
my advice I would spend my wedding ring
which was apparently some Freudian
indication that I was
you know sexually interested in a
particular complaining client now I
don't particularly blame her I mean had
she not had her problems she wouldn't
have come and seen me you know but the
college
has a tremendous gavel to wield a
tremendous hammer and to have that
brought down on you is it's no joke you
know and I've known a lot of people now
who've been investigated for that sort
of thing
um
by mobs let's say of one form or another
and it's very very hard on them so when
I re visited all this it was really and
I'd probably been avoiding doing it to
some degree you know although you know
we had to wait until we moved forward
with our legal challenge before we could
make any of this public there was still
an element of avoidance and no wonder
you know it really lit me on fire again
when I was going through this stuff but
one of the upsides was you know I
reviewed the and organized the
complaints that are levied against me
now the accusations for which I've
already been sentenced essentially and
uh the upside of it was that well these
accusations are so incredibly
Preposterous and political that it's
almost incomprehensible you know I'm
literally being well the the requirement
is so the college has decided
after pursuing these complaints that I
don't know how to regulate my behavior
properly in my social media
Communications and so I need to be
taught by their experts how to conduct
myself appropriately and so I have to
undergo a series of
courses uh one-on-one coaching sessions
with their deemed experts and they're
going to tell me how I should craft my
words and what I should say and what I
shouldn't say and I am required to pay
for that it's about 250 dollars an hour
which you know in our current
circumstances isn't a concern in and of
itself but you can understand that for
many people yeah that would be
tremendously burdensome
um and the person who's teaching me is
going to submit regular reports to the
college and they're going to decide when
I've learned how to be the sort of
person I should be so that I don't bring
disgrace upon the profession and harm
people and so the claims of harm are
absolutely unwarranted not a single
person who submitted a complaint in this
latest round is a client of mine
although half of them falsely claimed to
be so they're stable people their
complaints anyways well I think some of
it is they're probably confused about
the
what they're required how they're
required to identify themselves in the
Complaint Form to be fair okay or
they're just unstable people who spend
their time complaining about celebrities
on Twitter well well that's that's the
other office that's what you're doing
with your life you're probably not the
most stable person
yeah and and so anyways I've gone
through all these complaints and so
here's some of them I retweeted Pierre
poliov who's counted as leader of the
opposition when he was making when he
was criticizing the mask the mask
lockdowns I just retweeted him and I
said I said essentially that I agreed
with him that's a complaint they
actually listed that that's one of the
complaints that's insane
yeah yeah they listed the fact that I
criticized Justin Trudeau
on on multiple occasions there's a
complaint that at one point the police
in Ottawa were threatening to act with
Children's Aid to take the children away
from the truckers in Ottawa and
apprehend them on the grounds that their
parents who were involved in the protest
were endangering them and I tweeted and
said I'm not so sure that we should get
the police involved in taking away the
children of protesters and we should
think about this and apparently that
makes me uh
untrustworthy advocate for child
advocate for children who face childhood
sexuality oh my God the mandatory
reporter as a psychologist and so if you
if if it comes to your attention that
someone has been abused you're mandated
to report it
um and so apparently I'm now
untrustworthy in that regard because I
didn't want the police to conspire with
idiot social workers in Ottawa to
apprehend the children of protesters and
so that's another example of my
reprehensible behavior
um I'm being called out for the fact
that I uh
objected to Ellen pages
surgical mutilation at the hands of her
Physicians and her consequence
consequent advertisement of her new
torso on social media
and uh I'm also
required to submit to this
media retraining education because I
objected to the Sports Illustrated cover
of that um relatively overweight young
model and there's other complaints but
but that's that's the bulk of them and
so at least half oh yes I criticize oh I
I tweeted out to Jacinda Arden that I
was coming to New Zealand with my Army
of all right-wing trolls you know which
was clearly a joke and that's also a
complaint because I guess that sort of
joke isn't funny when you're dealing
with you know woke progressives like
Jacinda Arden and Justin Trudeau so um
oh yes I counseled people to commit
suicide that's another one so wait wait
you should somebody should describe oh
yeah describe that
yeah yeah well
somebody had tweeted out their idea that
the planet had too many people on it and
this is not a statement I am very fond
of because every time I hear someone say
that I think okay
who exactly are these excess people that
you're referring to and who gets to
decide that and how do you know that
when they decide that something terrible
won't happen given that these are excess
people and isn't it okay if I question
the humanitarian intent of your motives
for making such a reprehensible comment
so I tweeted uh to someone who made an
argument like that I tweeted and said uh
feel free to leave at any time and which
is obviously an ironic joke but some
bloody social worker in the United
States decided that that was a
um like an incitation to suicide and so
gladly about that and yeah and so and
that's I think I think that's all the
complaints so let's review this not a
single one of them was levied by a
client of mine present or former not a
single one of them was levied by anyone
I had actually said anything directly to
private or public there's no evidence
whatsoever of that I've produced
anything regarding harm because no one
has stepped forward to claim harm who is
directly harmed so it's third party
indirect supposition of so-called harm
to someone they don't know and that's
the level of evidence that the College
of psychologists is willing to accept as
critical you know now when they
responded to me they said that I've you
know brought disgrace to the profession
and caused undue harm to people and I
responded I'll make this public too with
about 40 questions about their methods
so here's one said well before I submit
myself to this media training
re-education because I'm Bound by the
ethical standards of my profession I'm
not willing to go get educated unless
there's evidence that the contents of
the educational program are directly
related to the practice of my profession
and that there's evidence that
undertaking such re-education actually
makes me a more competent therapist do
you have any independent documentation
that these experts that you have hired
and foisted upon me have anything
approximating genuine expertise and do
you have any evidence whatsoever that
such training programs are effective
and of course they said uh we don't have
to answer questions like that and I
asked them
I said you know there's some evidence
that I've done some good in the in the
world
um about seven million people bought my
first public book and I have 50 million
subscribers on the three main platforms
we operate on on social media and uh
lots of people seem to come to my
lectures when I am out publicly speaking
saying that I've really helped them in
their lives and that's thousands or
hundreds of thousands or possibly even
millions of people and so I think I can
stack up a pretty good plus all the
students that I taught at Harvard and
the University of Toronto and all my
clinical clients who by and large were
pretty damn happy to be working with me
and vice versa it's like how do you
calculate the harm to benefit ratio and
uh you know what evidence do you have
that I actually constitute a sufficient
threat to the Integrity of the
profession that you're willing to bring
the second harshest actions you have in
your Arsenal against and the answer to
that was we don't have to answer
questions like that and I had like 40
questions like that none of which were
answered their answer basically was we
can do whatever the hell we want
and we're telling you you better go get
re-educated or you face a disciplinary
hearing that's the next step is that I'd
have to face a disciplinary hearing and
what I'm going to do for that I do
believe they videotape that
and all take the videotape and put it on
my YouTube channel and people can decide
for themselves
which is exactly what I want to have
happen in this situation like you and I
talked about our strategy here
are you know and I have been
unbelievably angry about this so it's
been very hard for me to control my
anger you know and I know that's not
right and that my desire to seek
vengeance is inappropriate as is the
desire in general to seek Vengeance
right but it's uh it's very difficult to
read through these allegations and to
face this waste of my time and the
stress it puts on us to me and your
mother and well in our whole family
without being
outraged at this you know and a lot of
the battle for the last couple of weeks
has just been to keep my temper under
control but you and I we talked through
this and I talk through it with your mom
and with Julian you know about the fact
that
our attitude in general has been just to
tell everybody what's going on as
clearly as we possibly can and I want to
make it all public I'm preparing a
document today redacting all the names
of the complainants which I have been
provided with by the college by the way
I'm going to redact all their names and
that identifying information that's also
ridiculous just this just isn't set up
very well like you'd think that if you
were a problematic psychologist you
shouldn't be provided with the people's
names that complained about you
that doesn't seems
yeah well I don't know what to make of
that and it's also problematic that
people can Levy accusations that bring
down the heavy hand of a bureaucratic
organization and bear absolutely no
personal yeah ability to that like but
in a sane Society so that would have
been Canada up until about five or six
years ago people didn't weaponize the
colleges generally speaking you know
professionals weren't afraid of their
regulatory bodies because generally the
only people who complained were either
people who were clearly Disturbed you
know in some fundamental sense or people
who have legitimate reason to believe
that they had suffered harm
as a consequence of unprofessional
behavior on the part of a lawyer or
teacher or physician or psychologist but
the the uh radical leftist types have
figured out how to weaponize these these
investigative boards and the boards
themselves have become staffed pretty
much uniformly with social justice
oriented politically correct full
compassionate narcissistic commissars
and they do everything they can to make
life miserable for anyone who doesn't
share their political opinions I mean
it's actually it's actually almost
Beyond Comprehension to me that I'm
engaged in a battle in my country of
Canada
where I have to defend my right to
practice my profession as a licensed
psychologist and I would say especially
with my educational pedigree I mean
Jesus I was a professor at Harvard and
the University of Toronto I trained
clinical psychologists
you know and the fact that I have to
defend my right to conduct my own
profession because I retweeted a tweet
from the official leader of Canada's
conservative opposition party and
criticized Justin Trudeau and have made
at least upon occasion conservative
political pronouncements the fact that
that is now
that has now made me subject to
heavy-handed punishment and
investigation by a government sponsored
regulatory board is I just it's
absolutely incomprehensible and so
that's also I would say difficult
emotionally because
I just can't believe it's happening like
what the hell this is insane
and so
I mean and it's you know what the other
thing I think too it's so strategically
foolish on the part of the college I
mean it's one thing to go after me for
let's say
saying something not so
Pleasant about Ellen Page or about uh
the swimsuit Illustrated model at least
you could have an argument about whether
or not I was using undue force in my
argumentation on those grounds you know
but to Hillary me
for engaging in water clearly political
conversations is well
I don't even know what to say about it I
can't I can't believe it's happening
it's beyond comprehension to me and so
you know and that makes me think well
you know is it just me
you know because people tweet out at me
well Peterson you always seem to be in
trouble with one Authority or another
maybe it's just you it's like where
there's smoke there's fire you know and
uh
I can understand why people think that
way and if something happens to you
repeatedly you have to start wondering
if it's you or the situation but the way
that I'm dealing with this the way that
we've dealt with this as a family right
from the beginning is just to make it
all public right and to and to allow
light to be shown on the situation and
to derive our conclusions mostly as a
consequence of watching the broad public
response and I'm trying to do exactly
the same thing here like you know I'm a
very guilt-prone person and when some
come come someone comes after me with
accusations I'm very likely to assume
that there is a core of Truth in them
and uh but I also believe that I have
the right to defend myself and
one of the ways of doing that in this
situation this is why we're having this
conversation is like I don't
believe I don't have faith that I can
expect fair treatment at the hands of
this board and I also don't have any
faith partly because I've talked to a
bunch of my legal friends I don't have a
lot of faith in the Canadian Judiciary I
mean people have told me law professors
have told me now that they see
continually Canadian courts who are
extremely activist in nature dispensing
completely with such niceties as common
law precedent when they're rendering
their judgments and so yikes I certainly
don't believe that the College of
psychologists will treat me fairly I
have seen them treat very few people
fairly and I don't believe that even if
we push this forward on the judicial
front which is our plan at the moment
like implementing a challenge to their
ruling for example on on Canadian
constitutional grounds because at least
in principle we have the right free
speech and freedom of conscience in this
country I don't think we do yeah yeah in
principle yeah it's the protection has
turned out with the Canadian Charter of
Rights is an unbelievably weak and
poorly written document that provides
Canadians with almost no protection for
their rights whatsoever it was
definitely a giant step backwards in
relationship to the English common law
tradition and
um we're now subject to an
extraordinarily badly written document
whose fundamental propositions can be
superseded by the government anytime
they think there's a sufficiently dire
State of Affairs so so I'm making it
public and people can decide for
themselves I'll release every bit of
Correspondence between the college and
and me over the next few days you know
redacting out the identifiers and uh you
know I've been on your website I've been
ambivalent
yeah yeah yeah I've been ambivalent
about that too because part of me thinks
well these people who are complaining to
me they shouldn't get to do it
anonymously and hidden away from any
consequences of their accusations but I
believe that I'm legally and
hypothetically ethically required to
maintain privacy even in the face of
these what are essentially legal attacks
and you know I like I said I'm
ambivalent about that because I don't
see why I should be made public in such
a manner without my Accu accusers having
to Bear the weight of some
responsibility for weaponizing this
bureaucracy and against me now whatever
it doesn't matter that's because I'm not
going to do it because you've been
harming people on Twitter and they're
saving people from your harm
yeah I I that's that's the rationale
exactly well you know it's also been
difficult to formulate a defense because
I'm not even sure and and this is I
think
um part and parcel either of the
ignorance of the college or their
incompetence I can't even tell what I'm
being accused of so for example one of
the complaints submitted as evidence the
entire transcript of my three-hour
discussion with Joe Rogan and so you
know and I said all sorts of horrible
things on that yeah I know everything
that entire podcast was harmful yeah
yeah yeah so how do you defend yourself
against that
you know I mean I think they were
objecting primarily to my comments about
climate change models and the
apocalyptic conclusions that have been
derived from them and you know and
complaining that I'm not a scientist and
bloody well I am a Scientist by the way
I have a hundred scientific Publications
and that's a lot and I can read a
scientific paper and understand it
unlike those who are accusing me or the
people who sit on the college by the way
and so I'm perfectly capable of
understanding a scientific paper and I
believe and many scientists who are very
solid scientists like Richard Franzen of
MIT who has a pedigree that's absolutely
impeccable agree with everything I said
and so now that doesn't mean it's right
that's not my claim but my claim is is
that I'm not going off you know with a
half-loaded gun here and I don't say
things lightly but anyways it's not easy
to figure out exactly what I'm being
accused of and
so you know so the upshot is essentially
that he I either submit myself to this
media retraining program absolutely with
their experts yeah well that's not
happening there's just not a chance that
that will ever happen I can't imagine a
circumstance under which I would be
willing to do that I mean I can't
imagine how I would possibly sit through
such a thing that sounds you know
something I said I should just record it
and put it on no way on online and be
able to understand yourself
30 seconds in there
yeah well I don't know if I'd like to
put any educator through the horrible
process of having to come and try to
re-educate me either because I can't see
how that would go particularly well for
them yeah so yeah I'm not sure who would
end up re-educated in a situation like
that but I have my doubts that it would
be me because people have been trying to
re-educate me for a long time and it
really hasn't worked that well
so and that's generally because I I
don't say things that I haven't
investigated right to the bottom
so in any case it's very stressful this
and I've spent you know hundreds of
hours
just trying to organize the arguments
that have been marshaled against me and
understand what the hell they are you
know part of the process that's punitive
and the Bloody activists know this is
that as soon as you have complaints
levied against you you're basically
snowed under by the obligations of
what's essentially a serious lawsuit and
you know you might say well it's not a
lawsuit it's just an investigation it's
like well the college itself suggests
that once one of these investigations is
levied that the person being
investigated uh acquire legal counsel so
they know bloody well right that this is
essentially a criminal a quasi-criminal
investigation or at least it has that
element of process about it and the
social justice Warriors who are
utilizing these colleges have figured
that out and they're perfectly willing
to use third-party bureaucracy is as
cudgels to enforce their oh so
compassionate narcissistic world view
and to be censorious you know when you
see this on Twitter too as I've made
this public there are good thinkers
everywhere who are saying you know I got
what I deserved even though it isn't
obvious exactly why I deserved it and
I'm perfectly happy to see this
happening and you know that shows you
what kind of motivations a large
percentage of the population has you
know in Eastern Germany
a third of the population were KGB
informers
and so there's a very large swath of the
public of the public who would be
perfectly happy to see anybody who
doesn't share their political views
punished harshly for their audacity and
I think that's particularly true of
radical leftists in relationship to
anything that's Centrist or conservative
and it's very interesting like every you
know I don't only say conservative
things although in the current political
climate I suppose I am more conservative
but every single complaint that's been
levied against me
is because I uttered a conservative
perspective and so you know the
probability that that's merely a
consequence of chance is vanishingly
small it's one half times one-half 12
times and that's a pretty damn tiny
number so the idea that this isn't
politically motivated is preposterous
yeah conceptually unstatistically yeah I
I feel like we've had a lot of people
reach out to specifically from Canada
that are working professionals like
doctors I've spoken with a lot of them
who've had generally former patients
decide that they didn't like what they
were saying on Twitter specifically so
conservative doctors and they're like oh
I don't like what you're saying on
Twitter and then sending complaints to
colleges to get their licenses so I
don't think this is just happening to
you I think we've talked to a lot of
people oh it's not that it's happening
to which means what like what profession
does that mean you can't exactly trust
to tell you the truth anymore
Well you certainly can't trust
Physicians or psychologists because
they're mandated
with regard to
um to uh affirmative care now so for
example if you you can't assume that if
you take a child of yours whose gender
dysphoric in for professional evaluation
that they're going to get any evaluation
at all because psychologists and
Physicians are mandated to do nothing
but agree with the gender dysphoric
individual and so and and lawyers are in
the same situation as well is that
they're not
for example a while back the the
governing body of the legal profession
in Ontario mandated diversity equity and
uh inclusivity requirements in
relationship to hiring even on small law
firms in in Ontario with the clear
implication that if you didn't buy the
Dei social justice Warrior political
line that you were that your Law Firm
was no longer in concordance with the
dictates of the professional governing
body now Bruce party a law professor at
Queens fought that back forthrightly
with some success but I've had
discussions with all sorts of teachers
and nurses and lawyers and Physicians
all these people Canadians need to know
this all these people are so terrified
of a good proportion of these people are
so terrified of the regulatory bodies
that there isn't a hope in hell that
they're going to be able to tell you the
truth when you're in the middle of a
medical educational or legal crisis
and so you know in Canadians are in a
real bind because
you know for 175 years
it was okay in Canada to basically put
trust in the public institutions
educational institutions and
professional colleges and even the
political parties you knew what they
stood for and generally they played the
game straight and that's flipped
completely upside down in the last seven
years and that's a terrible bitter pill
for Canadians to swallow and most of
them don't even know it's happened
because their primary sources of news
like CBC is completely corrupted by its
1.4 billion dollar year payoff from the
federal government CTV isn't much better
most ordinary people have no idea where
to get news and so they're faced with
this terrible conundrum which is well
either things have gone badly sideways
especially toward the left in Canada or
the people complaining like me let's say
or the truckers for that matter are
misogynist racist alt-right-wing
Confederate Nazi bigots and it's a hell
of a lot easier to buy the latter than
the former and no wonder
but the unfortunate truth is well people
can decide that for themselves we'll
walk through this again I retweeted
Pierre pauliev
he's the leader of the opposition in
Canada
and because of that I'm being
investigated by my regulatory body
my public reputation is at stake and I
may no longer be able to practice or or
describe myself as a clinical
psychologist
and that's how it is
and it isn't just polio it's also the
fact that I criticized Trudeau and I
criticized an Ottawa city councilor and
I made a joke at Jacinda Arden and it's
not just fluke that every single one of
them is on the left
and that's how we are in Canada and it's
not like I don't have some sympathy for
the left you know I like Russell Brand
does what he can to stand up for
working-class types against corporate
overreach and corporate government
collusion to produce a kind of fascist
oppressive fascist overreach in
relationship to the working class and I
understand perfectly well that there's a
need for a left-wing political voice to
stand for the working class and
especially perhaps against the
depredations of monopolistic capitalists
but
that isn't what's happening on the left
in relationship to the sorts of things
we're talking about in the least
so
well so and it's going to be it's going
to be very hard for Canadians to wake up
to this reality I see no evidence
whatsoever that they've woken up yet oh
not at all not at all no so
well so we'll see what happens when we
make all of this public the next step
for the college is to haul me in front
of a disciplinary board and you know
rake me over the coals personally and I
don't imagine all
except their dictats when that happens I
can't imagine any circumstances under
which that would occur and then the next
step is to publicly announce my
refractory nature they've already
defined me as a repeat offender by the
way highly likely to real fend well you
are high that's their terminology it
seems like accurate terminology to me
Yeah well yeah I know well if the
offenses are defined as saying what I
think publicly then it's pretty much
certain I'm going to real fend but it's
hell of a terminology to be to be pasted
with you know repeat offender with a
high likelihood of real fending you know
so and do we have a timeline about how
long this is going to take and do you
what do you think the percentage what do
you think the likelihood is that they'll
take your license
well I I don't see what choice they have
because
the next thing look
what I would like from them because I
might as well make it clear I want every
single one of them to resign and to
apologize to me well that's not going to
happen
they can't reside seems highly unlikely
yeah it seems very unlikely and I don't
know if they're going to well they could
resign but if they don't stop what if
they just said you know what
out of 15 million people 12 complaints
isn't that bad given they're about
tweets and we've decided to stop
investigating you what if they just said
that well I don't see how well I don't
see how they can do that without
admitting that the whole bloody thing
was a scam to begin with because if it
was just one complaint they could say
well you know we've reconsidered and uh
you know we may have acted too hastily
but when you do it 13 times you know
three times is a pattern
13 times that's pretty much a decision
and if you have to announce publicly
that you were wrong 13 times
you're probably so wrong that you're not
fit for the job
[Music]
so so the alternative is I'm going to
make this public I've already told them
essentially to go to hell although I did
it politely and uh now they have to drag
me in front of a disciplinary hearing
which I will make
unbelievably public
and so and then because I won't move in
that regard as far as I can tell I don't
see that they have a leg to stand on you
know not only am I being accused in the
vast majority of the accusations of
having unacceptable political beliefs
but half the people who complain claimed
they were clients of mine
so procedurally this is also
a nightmare for them as far as I can
tell
because at minimum they should have
inquired in relationship to these claims
that the complainants were clients of
mine they should have noticed them that
they weren't and they should have
required them to re uh initiate the
complaint process without falsehood and
they didn't do any of that repeatedly
and you know that's particularly germane
because
if the complaint is levied by someone
who was a client the college is
obligated and also tends to take those
complaints much more seriously and to
facilitate their movement forward
so I think they've they're so
they've demonstrated such a brutal level
of incompetence and Corruption that I
can't see that they have any way forward
except to continue to pursue me or to
resign on Moss and
they're not going to do the latter
and so
I you know and this is a dreadful
you know I've met people Douglas Murray
is a good example I've met people in my
Voyage through this weird political
landscape who really liked this sort of
fight you know who are up for it and
this is not a criticism of such people
it's we need people like that you know
who are capable and willing to have a
scrap now the danger of that is that you
have more scraps than you should you
know and that you might be inclined to
take pleasure in it when you shouldn't
but I'm not that sort of person I hate
this it just it's really I find it
really really
difficult I like peace I mean part of
the reason I engage in conflict is
because I it's paradoxical in some sense
I really want peace and so if I have a
problem with someone I want to address
it right now 100 right to the bottom to
get it the hell out of the way so we
don't fight about it for the next 10
years you know and your mother and I
have conducted our whole relationship
with that yeah you know it's so funny we
had a date the other night upstairs you
know and she comes upstairs and this has
happened probably the last three days we
shot and she always has three [ __ ]
things to say to me before the date
starts and there what she does though is
she tells me some of the things that are
on her mind that are maybe interfering a
bit with our relationship
and they're minor things like I think
the last thing is we we were discussing
how to clean the sink so we were both
happy about it she wasn't exactly happy
with how I was cleaning the sink and you
know and then it was out of the way
and then it was completely out of the
way you know and then we had a very
peaceful time together because there
wasn't anything boiling away on the back
burner and when you and Julian were home
you know we conducted our family life
the same way if we had a bloody problem
we were going to have a discussion about
it right now and get to the bottom of it
and fix it so that we didn't hate each
other
and so I don't like and I never liked
those conversations I find them very
stressful I'm too high in negative
emotion and too high in agreeableness to
enjoy that sort of thing that's my you
know the detrimental consequences of my
feminine temperament to the degree that
I have that and it's quite the degree
actually
suppose that's partly what tilted me
towards being a clinician in the first
place right so and you know it's it has
its advantages because I do feel the
pain of other people
quite deeply but that also makes it very
hard for me to fight
even though
I'll fight when I know the consequences
of not fighting is more fighting
so yeah well that's a paradox you know
but it isn't because I enjoy it and yeah
you know I I tried to let the college
know
through backdoor channels that it might
be reasonable for them to consider not
doing this because the consequences of
making it public
would not be positive for the in my
estimation for the people involved and I
don't want to bring public pressure to
bear on people
without necessity because it's very
unpleasant to be at the center of that
kind of focal attention unless you're
narcissism bully people hide behind this
pseudo government organization and
pressure people I think if they get
negative feedback then they have more
than that coming to them
even being in Canada is unpleasant now
I feel like the political landscape has
ruined the country and it's because of
people who hide behind
well or just hide in anonymity and
pressure other people
for being harmful bureaucracy yeah so
whatever they shouldn't be bullying yeah
well
well they're not also bullying you like
obviously they're we've had other
doctors reach out to say that they're
being pressured their license is being
pressured because of their conservative
opinions on Twitter that's not what
these regulations are for
I talked to one of my great friends this
week a physician as well as a lawyer and
I suggested that maybe the three of us
write an article for the national post
about the state of
um regulatory bodies in Ontario and in
Canada more generally in the west more
generally and uh because I thought maybe
a one two three punch might be more
effective you know but my my friend
said that and he's very brave man and
also very very careful in what he says
and does he said his financial house
wasn't in sufficient order to initiate
that battle yet he wants to do it you
know but he still has but the point is
that even though he's a very brave man
and he's made a lot of public statements
already he's intimidated Enough by the
College of Physicians so that even
though he knows that this would be
politically effective he feels that he's
not well defended enough yet to take
this on fully and you know I can
understand that one of the things that
made me able to do this from the
beginning when the university came after
me was that I had three independent
streams of income right you know as a
professor I had a clinical practice and
I had a pretty successful business and
so I could lose two of those any two of
those without
you know being destitute and putting my
family at risk and I'm still in that
position now which is also partly why
I'm willing to do this publicly you know
because I don't want this precisely to
be about me because that's just annoying
I want to shed light on the fact that
this is a
on my belief that this is a universal
problem of public concern in Canada and
elsewhere and I can do that because the
worst thing the college can do to me is
well the worst thing they can do is
suspend my license and make a public
statement that because of my refusal to
comply with their dictates I'm no longer
acceptable as a licensed clinical
psychologist and I don't want them to do
that because I don't I believe that I
earned my license and am also a good
Advocate on the clinical front I don't
want to be in a position where faceless
bureaucrats motivated by a political
agenda and whatever envy and resentment
they carry in their dark and nasty
little hearts have the opportunity to
strip me of something that I spent a
decade of extremely hard work earning
and but you know if I if they do strip
it from me well
first of all that's not going to redone
to their credit second I can probably
get licensed in a jurisdiction like
Florida
um
that'd be satisfying yeah a creepy
little
Club of psychologists that are just
telling people lies anyway if the entire
profession is being forced to not tell
their clients the truth then maybe it's
worse than that it's worse than that
it's worse than that Michaela the uh the
the bodies that govern the training
programs for clinical psychologists in
Canada the Canadian Psychological
Association has increasingly moved to
make it mandatory for universities that
offer Clinical Psychology training to do
that under the rubric of social justice
or face the suspension of the
accreditation of their programs and
that's also happening in medicine you
everyone listening you bloody well
better listen to this people because
we're entering a situation where the
universities themselves are required to
ensure that your Physicians and your
psychologists are of a particular
political stripe which essentially means
radically left not just left but
radically left like social justice full
woke critical racist Theory oppressive
patriarchal narrative feminist left-wing
or the institution itself will not be
allowed to train Physicians or
psychologists and I know that sounds
like a conspiracy theory and well go
look it up for yourself and see if it's
true because it's true right down to the
last word and so if you Canadians you
think you're going to be served well by
craving political called ideologues who
are primarily selected to be Physicians
on the basis of their political Purity
you've got a bloody another thing coming
that didn't work out so well in Eastern
Europe let me tell you it's not going to
work out very well for us either and so
part of the reason I'm willing to make
this battle public is to try to alert
people to the fact that we're a hell of
a lot farther down this road than we
think
you know I went through Eastern Europe
for four months this spring talking to
people there I had the privilege of
meeting you know 30 or 40 people in each
country who were political or cultural
leaders across the political Spectrum
including leftists who'd be mobbed like
mad by their own compatriots and every
single one of the people I talk to
virtually without exception in Eastern
Europe said something like do you know
what happened here between the end of
the second world war in 1989 when we
were dominated by the Communists do you
know how awful it was here that was
particularly true in Albania do you know
you people in the west are walking down
exactly the same road what the hell is
wrong with you don't you notice and this
included the Socialists in those Eastern
European countries you know who remember
the Tender Mercies of the radical
leftists and the fact that you know one
out of three people in most of those
countries even if they're within your
own family were government in 4 farmers
and where the joke was we pretend to
work and they pretend to pay us and
where people spent hours in bread lines
and fought over terrible little Rat Hole
Apartments as they were quasi-starving
to death unable to ever tell the truth
or speak
yeah
that's not good
no no and that's why you're in Florida I
know Florida is great it's weird people
here are weird but it's it's good weird
it's free weird yeah it's not stifled
yeah well so Ronald right now
I hate it yeah yeah like I don't know
how you felt going back there and I
don't know how I've got lots of friends
in Toronto but it is not the same
Toronto as it was in 2015 or 2016. you
go there it's kind of like California
you can feel the weight of silence in
that place
yeah well your mom and I have been back
here for a month you know we're pretty
worried about coming back because we've
faced a fair bit of resistance in our
neighborhood like I'm probably more
unpopular in some sense in Toronto and
more particularly in my neighborhood
than I am anywhere else in the world
yeah and so it was somewhat worrisome to
come back to Toronto very worried Sun
moved out of our neighborhood in part
because it was uncomfortable for him to
be there even though that's where he
grew up
um thanks to the machinations of certain
neighbors it's been hard on your mom too
because I come downstairs well the other
day when I was going through what
happened in 2016 you know I came
downstairs I could hardly stand up a lot
of the symptoms I had over the last
couple of years came back and that's
really pretty frightening for me and for
her to see you know I had to sit down on
the floor five or six times
it sounds like this sounds like PTSD
well who knows you know what it is but I
recovered fairly quickly dude you know
an indication of my return to health
so but it's hard on your mom too because
I'm [ __ ] as can possibly be after
going upstairs and wrestling with this
material and you know we had a big
conversation this week about how she
should be involved because I don't want
to drag her into this and you know and
she doesn't want to blame me for being
entangled in it
and we don't want to stress our
relationship you know so I don't know
how much to protect her from this and
how much to share with her you know I
thought well maybe when I'm writing out
my college defense I should go to a
hotel room and you know grapple with it
there because
I'm much more irritable at least for
some period of time after confronting
all of this like it's calmed down a bit
now that I've got my argument you know
in order I've looked through all the
material there isn't any snakes left
under the carpet to bite me and so I
think I'm through the
most demanding part of it although God
only knows what's going to happen as
this unfolds because there's always the
possibility I'll make a mistake while
I'm defending myself too you know
because I could easily do that because
it's so complicated
but um but you know your mom and I are
on the same page in relationship to this
which is
you know she believes that if I just say
what's happening if I do my best to tell
the truth without adornment and to try
to keep my
volatile temper
under control that
this will turn out the way things have
turned out for us in the past which is
it'll be rather Dreadful in the short
term but
resolve
itself somewhat favorably in the medium
to long run
but that's easy to say when the medium
to long run has made itself manifest yet
yeah
this also might just be
this might just be something that's
that's happening that no one can really
get out of and by that I mean uh We've
we see what direction the universities
are going in so you can fight back
against that but basically at the moment
going to get a University degree seems
like maybe not the best idea if you end
up in hundreds of thousands of dollars
of debt being taught by ideologues and
then being taught information that won't
lead to a job just seems like a scam
right and if this is what's going on
with colleges and if they're controlling
working professionals so that the
working professionals have to work in a
way that isn't truthful I mean how do
you even fight how do you fight back
against that at what point do you just
stop playing in that game
well that you know people have asked me
that too why don't you just give up your
license and I would say well because I
wouldn't be giving it up I would be
allowing it to be taken away from me
like if I decide in a year that I don't
want to be a licensed clinical
psychologist because the whole damn
profession has become corrupt that's a
whole different issue than letting this
pack of Craven commissar cowards
organized behind the ski the scenes
utilize the complaints of random people
online to justify their own envy and
desire to prosecute and then fold in the
case of that opposition it's like I'm
not going to do that now now you say
well what do you do and I think the only
answer to that is I think in the only
thing you have in a complex situation
is the truth
that's all you have that's why you have
to abide by the truth you know because
when things get complex around you how
do I deal with this politically how do I
deal with this personally what do I say
in this terribly complex situation
all you have there that Solid Ground is
the truth and and one of the things to
reflect upon in relationship to that is
that's also why you have to live
honestly you know because it's very hard
to tell the truth if you're
simultaneously worried that the evidence
of your past misbehavior your past
deceitful misbehavior is going to come
to light and so the reason you abide by
the truth is so that you can say what
you have to say about what you've done
and who you are and you can do that
under impossibly difficult circumstances
and possibly that will sustain you
through that in uh you know in
circumstances where if that's not
possible you're just going to get
crushed you know and people might say
well being investigated by your
professional body isn't exactly a
life-threatening event and you're just
whining it's like look
for all you people who think that this
is such a walk in the park
I'll tell you two things number one I've
known about 200 people who face this
sort of thing now and every single one
of them every single one of them
with the exception of those people who
like a fight right of tiny tiny minority
of people maybe one or two in that
entire 200 they reacted as if they or
someone they loved had contracted a
life-threatening illness I've known
people very stable people extremely
elegant polished educated
well-positioned well-supported people
who literally ended up in psych wards
because of the pressure that was brought
to bear on them by the accusatory mob
and so those of you who think this is a
cakewalk you just bloody well wait till
your neighbors show up on your doorstep
with pitchforks and torches and you just
see what that's like for yourself
so you better watch yourself very
carefully if you think that the people
who are complaining about being mobbed
are just complaining because they can't
take it yeah so well that you also hear
you hear about I mean that that's a
silly thing to think too
um you hear about University students
who you can get bullied online it's not
life-threatening but it is
life-threatening to some people it can
make some people suicidal from stress
well look there's two great there's two
great classes of fear Michaela
there's only two one of them is death
death and physiological and
psychological disintegration so you
could think about that as the terror of
biological vulnerability
that's one class appears the Second
Great classifier is fear of social
exclusion and part of the reason is is
that historically if you're socially
excluded you're dead
so they're the same fear you know
because your social inclusion protects
you from dying right you work with other
people you cooperate with them you play
with them you you eat with them you're
dependent on their labor you're you're
literally sustained in your life by your
social desirability and your inclusion
and so if that's taken away from you
your reputation is solid or shattered
people shun you not only Are You
Lonesome and isolated but you're really
in trouble and your nervous system
reacts to that as if it's a mortal
threat which it is and so you know one
of the problems with
online culture and the culture of
anonymity you know people have been
pointing to this and saying well now are
you sorry that you've gone after
Anonymous trolls because look at what
happens if you're not Anonymous as I
think no I still think you people are
cowardly and most of you are narcissists
and you don't have the courage of your
convictions and
the problem of anonymity is that the
anonymous denouncers
get the upper hand and they're the
research is clear on this I just talked
to Dale paulus this week the the
developer of the idea of the dark Triad
and the dark Temple and there's a huge
body of research that's emerging showing
that online trolls especially the
anonymous types are much more likely to
be this is fun narcissistic
so that means they want social status
they believe they deserve social status
and that they should get it without
earning it Machiavellian which means
they'll manipulate other people
instrumentally to get what they want
independent of the consequences for that
person
Psychopathic which means they're
predatory and parasitical parasitical
meaning they're perfectly willing to use
your work as means for their sustenance
and this is the new part of the dark
tetrad which has expanded it beyond the
Triad sadistic love which means taking a
positive positive Delight in the evident
suffering of others not only failure to
experience that suffering so that
callousness that might be part and
parcel of you know being disagreeable
and and tough but actually experiencing
a positive Delight in the suffering of
others that's what laws means right
l-o-l-o-l-zed the plural of lulls of of
Elo sorry lulls l-u-l-zed is the plural
of LOL laugh out loud and to do
something for the lulls is literally to
do it online so that you can watch other
people squirm and suffer and that's
sadism and so paulus has been just you
know has been investigating
ordinary dark tetrad behavior and
looking at its contribution to online
Behavior it is certainly the case that
you know some of the complaints that are
levied Against Me by the Ontario College
of psychologists were just submitted to
the college as tweets
so they just used the college tagline at
CP Ontario to point oh my gosh to one of
my tweets and that was the complaint and
so these people who are willing to use
their anonymity to inform and accuse
have the upper hand in a virtualized
society you know and that's another
reason why I've you know I've had some
moral doubts about whether I should just
make all of this public like every bit
of the documentation everything the
college sent me which would include the
identifiers of the complainants but
and I'm still not sure that in the
fundamental most fundamental manner
that's not the appropriate thing to do
but because I'm not sure and because at
least technically my understanding at
the moment is that that's not
that I wouldn't be abiding by the
dictates of the college I'm still more
than willing to play by the rules and
those rules might be right you know I'm
I still I don't know what to do with
that because under normal circumstances
I can understand why the anonymity of
the complainant publicly would be
maintained right because it stops people
who have a legitimate grievance from
being intimidated by those against whom
they have the grievance but those rules
only apply when people aren't
weaponizing the colleges and as soon as
the colleges are weaponized when when
you can manipulate bureaucracy into
being a club for your Viewpoint then
what constitutes ethical behavior on the
part of the defendant starts to become
murky
and that's also part of what makes this
stressful yeah well I think it just
ignoring the people who actually did the
complaints is the right way to go
because they don't matter and if they
weren't there somebody else would be
making the same kind of complaint it's a
college issue right but that's a weird
argument right because and I you may
well be right and that's obviously what
we've decided to do too but there is
part of me that also thinks no you know
any given individual can cause a lot of
trouble if you set out to do that and
the idea that you shouldn't be
responsible for your accusations is
questionable especially when what you're
essentially doing is levying the
equivalent of a legal charge yeah I
think that's the right option it also I
think just on a more selfish level I
think it'll be easier given the fact
that this is going to be a battle for a
while and it might end
it might end badly I don't know how it's
going to end I don't trust Canada it
would be better for you emotionally not
to be involved in a personal way as much
as you can so like forget who the people
who made the complaints are even though
they're probably despicable human beings
there's tons of despicable human beings
out there better to just ignore them and
tell everybody what's going on and
ideally have a backup plan like if they
do come for your license can you just I
mean I assume getting a license yeah
well it's hard to know you know it's
hard to know if it's better to ignore
them there's lots of psychological
studies about
what people do to cheaters in games
and people are so motivated to punish
cheaters that they'll give up some of
their own privileges for the right to do
so and some of that's actually salutary
well look Michaela if you let the
cheaters get away with it they Dominate
and take everything that's the
psychopathic Niche that's why it even
exists biologically is because you can
get somewhere with exploitation and you
particularly get somewhere with
exploitation if the people you are
exploiting don't object
and so you actually have a moral
obligation to object you know to not let
people get away with breaking the rules
when people come after me well I don't
they can't just be let off the hook
right so it it's very but I we look I
think we've walked this through quite
appropriately is that no I should really
be concentrating on the college and not
the individual complainants I should be
concentrating on the college in a way
that has broad public significance
because this shouldn't just be about me
it's about a broader social problem that
we should use the truth and public
exposure transparency
to mount the best defense and we should
all keep our heads while doing so
but that's a
well there's no better strategy than
that but it's a tight rope to walk
that's for sure and the other problem is
Mick
it's so easy to slip off this you know
it's like when I've been in the most
tendentious interviews that have been
directed at me
um Helen Lewis comes to mind in
particular every single comment that
some of these journalists have made is a
trap
right and the trap is I think I could
goad you into saying something that
would be impulsive and aggressive enough
to Blacken your reputation permanently
so and therefore to destroy your life in
some fundamental sense just so that it
would redound to my moral credit and if
you all listening think that I'm being
paranoid you go read Nelly Bowles
apology for what she did as a New York
Times journalist yeah and you tell me
that this isn't true because she came
right out and said that's exactly what
she did when she worked at the New York
Times
now she thinks she's learned better but
I would say if you already went that far
in that direction you have an awful lot
of learning to do and I would be very
hesitant to claim you've now learned
your lesson and are a good person
you know there's some things that it
takes a long time to come back from and
that's certainly one of them I would
happily destroy someone's reputation
just so that my articles got more
attention online it's like oh yeah
really and you knew that too you didn't
just do it unconsciously you did it
consciously and you did it repeatedly
and you did it for the New York Times
and now you're sorry it's like yeah
10 years in a Convent flagellating
yourself might make you sorry
maybe like I've watched people in my
clinical practice try to walk back from
significant moral errors it is not that
easy you know there's that Catholic
doctrine that you can be saved and
redeemed no matter what your sin
it's like that's true but that doesn't
mean you have you don't have to face the
consequences of what you've done
and like if you want to repent and
you've done something seriously wrong so
much of you have to change has to change
that it's almost like you have to die in
order to be reborn
so anyways for those who are listening
that's another reason why you should try
to step forward carefully in your life
you know because you will be called to
attend for your misbehavior and it will
occur during a period of Crisis and if
you're a mess and a deceitful mess
you're going to find yourself in trouble
so profound you can barely imagine it
so
anyways I don't know kid this isn't
really what I wanted to do on your
birthday
this is exactly what I wanted to do on
my birthday
and we'll keep people updated we can do
another update podcast
and you're going to record anything that
happens in the future I think that's
more than fair record everything as much
as possible and just drink yeah yeah
yeah yeah
definitely yeah yeah I'm not doing any
of this behind closed doors so enough of
that if it has to be done behind closed
doors you know unless I'm convinced that
there's a real concern for
confidentiality if it has to be done
behind closed doors the reason for that
is either they're you know justifiable
concerns for privacy or a kind of
corruption that can't bear public
scrutiny and since this is a public
inquiry as to my suitability to speak
publicly as a clinical psychologist I'm
perfectly willing to
um what ensure that the show trial is as
broadly attended to as possible
so anyways I have no idea how this is
going to go Mick I mean who do I I'm I'm
gonna oh I wrote Trudeau I wrote Justin
yesterday and just let him know what was
happening yeah yeah I and said you know
um turns out that I'm having my
professional license threatened because
I don't agree with you which I certainly
don't and uh I just thought you know you
might be interested knowing that this is
occurring on your watch and so anyways I
wrote him and then I sent that to the
National Post and they said they wanted
to publish it as an op-ed so I added a
introductory paragraph and a concluding
paragraph Just to let everybody know the
context and that's going to be published
tomorrow and I know a number of
reporters who are going to cover this in
the next few days and
it'll give some International attention
soon and so what do you think is going
to happen
hmm
I think yes
I think if I had to guess
I think that they'll say
you know what after looking into these
we realize that these are just random
people on Twitter complaining and we're
going to throw them throw them out and
not pursue you further I think that's
what my guess is the alternative is
they'd literally take your license and I
think that that's also easily possible
but it would be such a public war and it
just it shows
that their system is broken it's obvious
that the system is broken if that's what
happens if they take your license for
your opinion tweets
it shows that their system is broken I
don't think that they can let that
happen and eventually someone will
figure out what's happening and say guys
you have to let this go somebody at the
top yeah what do you think well I don't
know I don't know I don't know you know
because I keep thinking that you know
the tide will turn and this is
self-correcting but everything's
self-correcting in the long run yeah but
you know when the Israelites were
wandering through the desert that was
three generations so the long run can be
a very long time and things
self-corrected in the Soviet Union to
some degree but it took 60 years and you
know 30 to 40 million deaths and so
things can fall apart pretty damn badly
and if we think we're immune to that in
a place like Canada it's just because
we're you know so sheltered we're naive
beyond belief it isn't clear to me at
all that
a third of Canadians have virtually no
Allegiance whatsoever to the ideas of
freedom of Association Allegiance
conscience and expression the rapidity
with which Canadians particularly in
Toronto leapt forward to adopt all the
restrictions of the master debates was
absolute evidence of that and there's
still plenty of people who who are more
than happy to have their masks on and
who I think would wear them for the rest
of their lives especially if they had
the extra Delight of being to tell of
being able to tell other people that
they also had to wear them so I don't
know what'll happen kiddo I mean
what do I think will happen
I think
I don't think that they'll do what you
said at least in the immediate future
because I think they made too many
decisions already to backtrack without
the kind of embarrassment that shouldn't
necessitate resignation and so I think
what will happen is they'll pray
devoutly that I go the hell away and I'm
actually afraid of their you know their
uh their public hearing but I'm not in
fact I'm much less afraid of that
because I can represent myself then I'm
much less afraid of that than of
anything we're doing presently and so I
think they'll go through with that I
think they have to
I don't know there's two endpoints they
resign and apologize
or they walk this through and take my
license those are the options
so I guess it depends how badly Canada
is going to fall before it it corrects
itself because I think the Universe
I think the universities are dead I
don't know if the you know doc colleges
that are around for doctors those might
be dead too
the classic the classic Hallmark of a
tyrant is that under duress they Double
Down
so I suspect what they'll do now is
they'll release something like a public
statement indicating that my vociferous
attempts to defend myself are nothing
but my utility of my own proclivity for
bullying to bring the weight of my
alt-right followers unfairly to bear on
this issue
so they'll play the victim card right
despite the fact that
that I have left them alone 100 percent
and that the reverse isn't true now
they'll say Well they're just doing
their professional Duty it's like well I
guess that's what the dispute's about I
don't think you're just doing your
professional Duty
I think you're a pack of envious
Scoundrels hiding your own incompetence
behind the opportunity to persecute
that's what I think and so you know when
you think I'm in reprehensible alt-right
bully it's like okay
I think you're wrong about that let's
have it out
we'll see what everyone thinks when the
when the dust settles
so I guess that's where we're at kiddo
yep and we'll keep everybody posted
online we'll link the article
um in the YouTube description yep and
all all and we'll link this document
that makes all the correspondence that's
relevant and legally appropriate
available